bienvenue dans cette émission spéciale
consacrée aux 40 ans de saint quentin en
yvelines émission pour sacrer à la santé
comment dans un territoire dont la
population s'est multipliée par dix en
40 ans sourit en place les
établissements et les services qu'elles
ont été les problèmes qui ont été
rencontrés quels seront les problèmes
que nous rencontrerons demain pour en
parler avec d'autres daniel vialla vous
tuer vous êtes de conseillère déléguée à
la santé propose un comité de
préfiguration
isabel rochât
bonjour vous êtes directeur est de gérer
handicap
alors a évidemment dans cette émission
malines vraiment marchessault bon si
vous êtes directrice de l'institut de
promotion de la santé et puis gens
inaptes de bayou vous êtes le directeur
du mot fond du premier institut qui
avait vu quelques jours sur 7 directoire
qui est l'institut marcel rivière alors
je te prouve à tout de suite abordé mal
d'histoires les premiers pas de la santé
dans le territoire
alors je vais peut-être commencé avec
vous cet institut e marcel rivière c'est
en effet le premier établissement qui
voit le jour sur ce territoire en 1959
effectivement donc bien avant rien à
boire le thé rien avancer l'affairé
existe effectivement donc décision de
créer un établissement spécialisé qui
n'accueillait à cette époque que les
enseignants qui avaient du mal avec
leurs différents actifs qui avaient
déserté professionnels déjà
venus d'établissements ouverts à tous et
notamment à la population
et bien c'est devenu un établissement
ouvert à tout le monde d'une part parce
que la mgen a fait le choix en 1976 de
devenir psph participant au service
public hospitalier de ce fait elles
s'ouvraient à tout le monde donc elle a
fait ce choix là pour tous ces
établissements les instituts
marcel-rivière donc dès 1976 est le
deuxième établissement l'hôpital denis
forestier qui est également sûr sur la
verrière a également été ouvert à tout
le monde depuis cette époque là
d'établissement important
pour le territoire de saint quentin en
yvelines oui bien sûr la verrière un
d'établissement important qui est en
pleine restructuration aussi monsieur de
bayod pourra peut-être en dire un mot et
qui justement va orienter de ses
activités en restructurant les activités
actuelles de façon offrir aussi une
ouverture plus large à la population
avec même des consultations ouvertes aux
habitants donc du territoire voire même
au delà du territoire puisque saint
quentin en yvelines n'est pas fermée ce
n'est pas un territoire enfermés dans
des frontières c'est un territoire
ouvert vous êtes arrivé ici je crois
dans les années 80 je suis ensemble
encore mais je la suis arrivé en 1982
sur 82 comment vous avez trouvé ce
territoire à l'époque il y avait peu de
construction puisque la gare elle-même
était encore au milieu de champs de maïs
de blé ou de betterave et donc
historiquement la prise en compte de la
santé sur sur le territoire ça s'est
fait petit à petit avec l'implantation
d'associations d'institutions etc mais
la prise en compte de la santé au sens
agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines c'est quelque chose qui date
déjà puisque déjà en 1994 dans le plan
santé ville la prise en charge dans le
plan ii
de la ville c'était une une
préoccupation dit m la santé donc
d'avoir un volet santé et qui s'est
orientée autour de la santé mentale de
la santé des jeunes la santé des
personnes âgées et des personnes
handicapées et puis arrêtez la santé
précarité grégarité jeu revient
justement sérieux puisque vous dirigez
aujourd'hui l'institut marseillais
savaient d'établissement qui reçoit
combien de personnes aujourd'hui c'est
un établissement qui a une autorisation
pour 280 lits nous avons des prises en
charges qui sont spécialisées
c'est-à-dire que nous avons dit à petit
la psychiatrie la personne âgée nous
avons des unités d'addictologie des
troubles du comportement
pour les jeunes adultes psychotique et
nous avons également une unité
d'adolescents unités fermées
intersectorielle pour les adolescents il
ya aussi des liens avec la culture parce
que je crois qu'elle notable au black
blanc beur qui investit de temps en
temps votre établissement effectivement
nous avons un très beau théâtre à
l'intérieur de l'institut un théâtre qui
peut accueillir 400 places et dans
lequel plusieurs troupes ont été en
résidence au fil des années ça c'était
une volonté c'était une volonté dès 1959
parce que la culture faisait partie
partie intégrante de la réinsertion
d'agréer des malades et dans tous les
établissements de ce type là il y avait
volonté d'avoir un théâtre une ouverture
sur tout sur le monde culturel on
remarque une chose peut-être il n'y a
pas d'établissement public au fond c'est
souvent ce que dit monsieur le président
cadalbert on a posé souvent la première
pierre d'un hôpital sur saint quentin en
yvelines et on n'a jamais eu d'hôpital
d'où la volonté en fait politique de nos
espérances parce que les prix des
priorités était à donner à des
constructions ou des réhabilitations et
c'est mignot à versailles qui a été
retenue pour sa transformation les shows
à l'obtiennent mignot vise pour sa
transformation et ce à son rayonnement
l'établissement privé
lâche p au p l'hôpital privé de l'ouest
et de l'europe voilà elle est là avec un
plateau technique qui était déjà fin
voilà je pense qu'il est toujours joueur
qui est toujours à qui se bat parfait
mais parce que dans ces années passées
mais c'est vrai c'est un ado technique
est très très important donc je pense
connus ou inconnus fait vraiment un
service public c'est à dire que qui
offre une offre de santé à tout le monde
sur le spirit la jambière de bayod je
vais vous remercier parce que vous allez
remplacer dans quelques instants par
jacques weber qui est un médecin sur le
sur ce territoire mais on va pas vous
quitter totalement puisqu'on va
justement s'intéresser au service six
ados de l'institut marc saint trivier
alors c'est un sujet un peu historique
merci beaucoup à vous on regarde ce
sujet on se retrouve tout de suite après
au départ l'unité de psychiatrie de
l'adolescence de l'institut marcel
rivière comptait huit lits dès 2002
l'effectif est passé à 15 lits depuis le
pavillon ne désemplit pas les jeunes
accueillis ici sont envoyés par les
urgences leur médecin généraliste ou
leur psychologue parmi l'équipe 18
infirmiers un kinésithérapeute un
ergothérapeute deux psychologues ainsi
qu'un praticien hospitalier
encadre les patients qui manifestent des
troubles mentaux tels que la dépression
des problèmes alimentaires ou une
anxiété excessive le déclenchement d'une
d'un trouble mental ne se fait jamais
comme ça il ya un terrain personnel il
ya des circonstances extérieures et il
ya des facteurs socioculturels au moment
de l'adolescence qui est un âge critique
d'art c'est un âge de révolte c'est un
âge où le sujet commence à prendre
conscience de son propre corps
commencent à prendre conscience de sa
liberté quand même temps il n'a pas
énormément de liberté et qu'il a pas de
possibilité de se projeter dans un
avenir pour se représenter comment il
sera plus tard c'est un âge vraiment
critique ou
les modalités de réponse à cet âge
critiques peuvent être variables souvent
des mises en danger personnage au delà
des soins psychologiques le corps
médical assure également une prise en
charge biologique et sociale des
patients la dynamique de groupe et
l'association étroite des parents font
partie des points fondamentaux du
travail thérapeutique
d'une manière générale les résultats
et ça c'est pas spécifique à notre unité
un sens c'est tout le champ de la
psychiatrie de l'adolescent sont plutôt
bons c'est un âge où les troupes sont
très aiguë très bruyant et en même temps
beaucoup plus facilement résolutives que
plus tard
des résultats encourageants dû à une
prise en charge complète du patient mais
aussi à une collaboration accrue entre
les professionnels des différentes
établissements médicaux
nous avons
bon jour alors vous êtes vers iata et
vous avez été aussi médecin généraliste
vous êtes installés en calade et s'est
installé en 91 après quelques années de
remplacement sur le secteur donc je
connais le puits mettant
88 et qu'on s'était alors dans les
années 90 ce plan médical pour un
généraliste
les choses qui ont changé je pense qu'il
y avait effectivement des confrères de
terrain qui était bien implanté qui
connaissait bien la population
on avait probablement une proximité il
ya les choses essentielles c'est la
pratique c'est à dire qu'il y avait
beaucoup plus en particulier de prise en
charge de visites à domicile par exemple
car inquiets chose qu'il ya une
permanence des soins qui est assurée
autrement parce qu'on avait des gardes
ce qui est plus la même chose il ya 25
ans et grands c'était un travail assez
difficile non matin je pensais rester
mon avis à peu près stable
je ne pourrais pas vous donner des
chiffres objectifs slater mais le
sentiment que vous
ressentirez un médecin ventre pour 500
800 habitants qu'est ce qui vous a
poussé à vous installer sur ce
territoire parce que j'y habitais déjà
jamal quelques années sans se trouver
que le coin était ma foi sympathique
pour la région parisienne les atteintes
voilà voilà et puis bon après je l'avais
déjà des opportunités de travail fini
c'est encore mes études
initialement je remplaçais finalement de
fil en aiguille les choses sont faites
naturellement
alors on va avancer un petit peu dans le
temps est arrivé à 2001 avec coups mc
alignement marchessault avec cette
création de deux styles promotion de la
santé qu'est ce que c'est un
mois ses objectifs alors l'objectif avec
la styliste roczen la santé donc dès son
ouverture en 2001 c'est de fédérer les
acteurs de la santé en fait les acteurs
à la fois du secteur sanitaire du
secteur médico-social et du secteur
social
pour
me dire améliorer le parcours de santé
en fait du de l'habitant améliorer aussi
bien en faire un lien entre les avis
fédérer voilà
on a aussi eu un rôle de l'information
information à la fois de la population
mais aussi des professionnels qui
interviennent sur le territoire mais il
me l'aviez la douleur l'a dit libé s
c'est aussi ça va même au delà en fête
de saint quentin en yvelines puisque on
héberge une un peu plus de 20
partenaires qui dont l'intervention va
au delà des frontières de saint quentin
surtout si divine et même pour certains
de nos partenaires comme l'association
française du diabète comme voilà des
choses comme ça ça va surtout
département leur intervention a lieu sur
tout le département donc mais notre rôle
principal c'est de l'ailier
qui pendant une petite équipe de la
communauté d'agglomération et on a ce
rôle de de créer du lien
d'accompagner aussi les actions de santé
sur le territoire
de permettre de mieux connaître le
territoire aussi donc d'observer la
santé du territoire des habitants afin
de nous voilà des besoins de ses
habitants et afin de répondre à ces
besoins de façon adaptée coordonnées
d'une façon cohérente sur le territoire
des actions sur la prévention sur le
petit doigt levé sur les soins
palliatifs on a parlé un petit peu tout
à l'heure c'est cette expo pas dans les
virages de profond de l'intervention
j'allais dire politique et enfin c'est
exactement exactement donc je disais
tout à l'heure première intrusion santé
en 94 et puis création donc de
l'institut de promotion de la santé qui
est donc un service de la communauté
d'agglomération avec les buts que
marilyn vient d'exposer et puis petit à
petit
une avancée puisque 2006
saint-quentin-en-yvelines reçoit le
label oms ville sans rien mais c'est
important première communauté de l'asean
ça veut dire qu'on pense non parce que
en fait c'est l'entrée dans un réseau
aussi qui prône et bien l'égalité en
santé qui prône aussi la santé dans avec
tous ces déterminants en santé c'est à
dire la santé et l'habitat la santé et
l'urbanisme la santé et la culture la
santé dans sa vaste environnement c'est
à dire faire montrer la santé dans la
réflexion de tous les acteurs qui
travaillent sur ces champs la renvoie
passagers ont dû d'abord des questions
au pot généralistes que vous étiez
vous
avez des liens comme ça avec avec 10 ps
avec la communauté pour un médecin c'est
important ou est-ce que vous êtes très
indépendant de ça je crois que c'est
quand même c'est une nouveauté en tout
cas
c'était c'est vrai que l'image qu'on a
des généralistes et qui travaillent un
petit peu individuellement ils sont une
patientèle maintenant c'est quelques
jours déjà un peu anciens parce que
maintenant le fonctionnement yeux contre
avec un beaucoup plus en lien en réseau
en partenariat effectivement avec des
structures un peu innovantes comme ce
qui se passe sur saint quentin en
yvelines est donc là on va s'orienter
vers effectivement probablement une
prise en charge plus globale plus de
partenariats des changes
et de continuité de soins donc ce qui
est toute façon dictée probablement par
la démographie médicale mais
probablement dans perdra en avril alors
qu'ils avaient la voie en charge des
handicaps c'est quelque chose de très
important c'est à magny les hameaux oui
il faut se dire pourquoi
ce prix monsieur sub sur justement le
handicap
pour pour créer une cohérence au niveau
de la prise en charge de la perte
d'autonomie sur le territoire et puis
comme comme on l'a dit de façon de façon
plus large pour vraiment créer un
maillage et une synergie des différents
partenaires que ce soit des
professionnels du secteur de la santé
mais du secteur médico-social et du
secteur social existe
des nouveaux c'est une nouveauté
alors l'étape projet date de 2004 les
statuts juridiques du groupe mandat
d'octobre 2009 c'est le premier
groupement de coopération sociale
médico-sociale en ile-de-france en tous
les cas qui a cette formule au monde et
donc voilà c'est comme une nouveauté
comment ça se passe vous accueillez des
personnes handicapées alors le
groupement au sens vraiment plus large
et déjà la réunion de différents
dispositifs
de statuts différents donc qu'il ya la
communauté d'agglomération il ya des
associations il ya un établissement de
santé pour vraiment créer un maillage
des entreprises qui vont qui vont
participer sous la forme d'une
convention de partenariat
dans le cadre de formations que l'on
peut donner sur sur la perte d'autonomie
et l'intégration de salariés en
situation de handicap
donc c'est vraiment créé le maillage et
les réseaux de partenaires le plus large
sur cette question de la perte
d'autonomie pour vraiment que une
logique soit faite au niveau du
territoire ça aussi ça a été les
volontés politiques ah oui oui ça a été
très belle aventure et
avec une condition pourquoi
ça a été je dis très belle aventure
parce que il ya eu énormément de force
qui ont été mises là dedans pour pour la
création et à partir du moment où la
création a vu le jour c'est quelque
chose qui fonctionne bien qui qui rend
le service attendu puisque c'est prendre
en compte l'autonomie des personnes que
c'est cette autonomie soit mise en
danger par le handicap ou simplement par
l'âge donc
ce qui explique d'ailleurs cette
contraction gérant taux
est en fait c'est dès l'origine de dolly
ps en fait qu'ils aient eu cette
réflexion autour de la presse la prise
en compte du maintien à domicile des
personnes âgées des personnes
handicapées en fait et c'est parti de là
où j'ai tendu du premier contrat de
ville et puis ce qui était intéressant
aussi c'était le travail avec
public privé pour mettre en place ce
âgées handicap puisque c'est peut-être
une des particularités septième départ
était de priver d'une façon générale il
existe pas puisque vous parlez de la
coordination de ses différents services
il ya un contrat local de santé qui a
été signé au mois de décembre
il est tout récent qui est tout récent
et donc barreau va regarder consiste ce
contrat local surveille ça nous
permettra d'aborder la troisième partie
de cette émission c'est à dire qu'est ce
qui va se passer dans les années qui
viennent
un outil pour lutter contre les
inégalités sociales et territoriales de
santé c'est ainsi qu'a été présenté le
contrat local de santé ou cls signé la
semaine dernière à l'institut de
promotion de santé de trappes un
document qui engage le département la
communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et l' agence
régionale de santé pas de grande
nouveauté il s'agit surtout selon les
signataires de permettre l'articulation
de différentes composantes du système de
santé sur certains territoires saint
quentin est la première collectivité à
signer un cls car elle répondait à
plusieurs critères c'est à dire une
ville dans laquelle il y avait déjà une
dynamique de
le contrat urbain de cohésion sociale
avec un volet santé notamment des
ateliers santé ville mais aussi parce
que c'était une communauté
d'agglomération au sein de laquelle il y
avait des territoires qui objectivement
était en situation de vulnérabilité
le contrat local souligne des disparités
importantes sur le territoire saint
quentinois en première ligne la verrière
et sa population vieillissante et rap
jugées en situation difficile chômage
taux de mortalité infantile le plus
élevé du département et une espérance de
vie réduite par rapport à la moyenne
yvelinoise en conséquence plusieurs
objectifs retenus par le cls améliorer
l'observation de l'état socio sanitaire
de la population fluidifier les parcours
en santé mentale améliorer les parcours
de santé des populations vulnérables
réduire les inégalités sociales de santé
en lien avec l'environnement et
favoriser l'implantation de
professionnels de santé une démarche qui
devrait être facilité par l'implantation
de l'ufr de médecine à montigny le
bretonneux mais pas seulement d'autres
efforts restent à faire pour éviter la
désertion de certains secteurs la chaîne
professionnelle il a parfois envie
d'avoir un mode d'exercice différentes
et ancien mais pour qu'ils viennent
s'implanter dans une commune dans un
territoire dans lequel n'y a pas
aujourd'hui de professionnels il faut
qu'il soit un peu parrainer qu'ils
soient un peu accompagnés par des
professionnels existants donc c'est ce
lien qu'il faudra instaurer et sur
lequel s'engage d'ailleurs des unions
professionnelles dans la région ile de
france cinq autres contrats devraient
être signés dans les yvelines les
signataires s'engagent sur six ans un
premier point sera fait fin 2012
dans ce sujet au pâlot si c'est un des
problèmes qui commencent à apparaître je
crois sur le territoire le problème de
la désertification d'une certaine
désertification friserait médical c'est
à dire que ben il ya pas mal de médecins
qui partent à la retraite qu'ils cessent
leur activité ne serait pas forcément
tous remplacés non c'est une enquête que
nous avons menée il y à déjà plus de
deux ans deux ans et demi et sur le
territoire pour voir un petit peu
qu'elle était l'espérance de de présence
de professionnels de santé qu'ils soient
médecins ou
paramédicaux sur le territoire et on
s'est rendu compte que à 5 ans 10 ans on
avait une un départ de professionnels de
santé assez important donc on s'est dit
c'est tough cette question là il faut
pas la laisser venir dans cinq ans dans
dix ans il faut commencer déjà à y
réfléchir est-ce que c'est dans ce cadre
là qu on a déjà mené des travaux il ya
déjà des mesures qui
justement donc le
on a quand même la chance d'avoir une
faculté de médecine qui s'installe sur
le terreau à la fois bon voilà c'est
pour nous c'est un atout sur lequel on
va jouer bien entendu de façon à
fidéliser aussi les étudiants qui vont
venir faire leurs études ici leur
montrer que le territoire est attractif
de façon à ce qu'ils aient envie de s'y
installer d'y fonder une famille va y
avoir d'ailleurs un nouveau bâtiment qui
va être construit pour accueillir parce
que voilà donc la maison de l'étudiant
il va y avoir aussi du côté du vélodrome
un certain nombre de structures plus
actives ont abrité les chercheurs et les
étudiants donc oui alors un problème un
des problèmes justement contre la
désertification médicale on vous y
répondre et notamment avec avec la
formation de futurs médecins autre
problème vous êtes passé
doctor de médecins généralistes et la
gériatrie c'est le vieillissement de la
population vous c'est quelque chose que
vous avez constaté je suppose mois avec
une carrière un peu atypique parce que
moi j'avais une activité mixte
initialement pital elirale et avec une
activité très orientée en gériatrie dès
le départ j'ai participé à la création
d'un réseau j'étais médecin
organisateurs pour la part donc j'étais
aussi je me suis occupé beaucoup de
personnes âgées dans le cadre du bien
être social est ce que c'est un des
facteurs importants sur le territoire
population âgée qui contiennent
justement des services différents je
pense qu'effectivement le vieillissement
de la population il est palpable 1
pour faire l'écho aussi du devenir des
soignants lui aussi un des baby boomers
vont des papy boomer bientôt donc un
fort de taux de départ en retraite de
soignants médecins par un média co
espère kiné ce qui est pas sans poser
problème d'où la réflexion je pense
effectivement sur le territoire de
comment on va faire demain comment on va
faire face à cette demande demande de
soins demande de prise en charge de
perte d'autonomie géré handicap est une
réponse
je crois que c'est important en tout cas
de d'envisager les choses avec des
diversités de pratiquer ne plus
continuer à fonctionner comme on pouvait
le faire avec un médecin dans son
cabinet gérant tout seul sa patientèle
et voilà je crois que ça s'est un temps
t d'interviews qui qu'il y avait à
ce terme idée donc à la nouvelle a parlé
de l'importance est évidemment de la fac
de médecine qui s'intéressent à l'est
sur le territoire mais justement on va
voir un sujet sur la pose de la première
pierre de cette université
l'université de versailles-saint-quentin
n'arrête pas de grandir bientôt un
observatoire du climat une maison de
l'étudiant est un nu fr des sciences et
de la santé une fac de médecine au sens
large ça apporte des laboratoires de
recherche des partenariats
complémentaire avec l'ensemble du monde
socio-économique et puis aussi comme on
le disait des nouvelles formations pas
seulement pour faire médecine comme on
l'entend traditionnellement mais pour
tous les métiers paramédicaux
pas mal pour une université qui fête ses
20 ans et cumule les distinctions entrée
au classement international de shanghaï
et décrochages en 2009 de la première
place aux examens d'internât un
dynamisme saluée par la ministre de la
recherche qui a rappelé que le budget
alloué à lui vs qu avait progressé de 40
% depuis 2007 et que l'université
s'inscrivait naturellement dans le
projet de paris saclay le fait d'avoir
une fac de médecine le fait d'avoir des
sciences humaines et sociales à
versailles saint quentin qui ne sont pas
présents dans le cadre du plateau de
saclay fond de versailles-saint-quentin
vraiment j'allais dire un complément
naturel de ce qui se construit à saclay
avec un voeu pieux du président de
l'agglomération que 55 devienne le
quartier latin de la région parisienne
en attendant les étudiants vont surtout
apprendre un métier des métiers en voie
d'extinction on sait que dans dix ans
ils seront la plupart en retraite
aujourd'hui il ya eu pendant dix
médecins qui sont partis en retraite
dans les yvelines et n'a qu'un seul qui
l'a remplacé et d'avoir l'ufr de santé
sur notre territoire c'est un plus parce
que hbo en ancrant notre université sur
le territoire c'est sûr qu'un grand
nombre de ces jeunes qui vont se former
vont rester sur le territoire
tout cela devrait aller assez vite grâce
à la signature d'un partenariat
public-privé le dossier a été monté en
quatre ans livraison du bâtiment 2012
isabel rochât vous et vous accueillez
vous aussi âgées handicap des étudiants
en médecine effectivement dans le cadre
des liens qu'il ya entre géré handicap
et la faculté de saint quentin ils ont
nous accueillons actuellement deux
stagiaires étudiants en médecine externe
sur un stage d'une période de dix
semaines préparé avec le dr weber et
alors il faut dire un mot de ce qu'il va
se passer au mois de mai oui au mois de
mai au mois de mai une une magnifique
une manifestation importante la semaine
de l'autonomie du 30 mai au 2 juin qu'on
veut d'envergure un petit peu
européenne voire nationale puisque et
évolué pendant internationale se
mobilisera il y aura le colloque de
l'inrs tas et les rencontres européennes
sur le maintien à domicile également
organisées pendant 7o personnes âgées
handicap voilà merci infiniment à tous
les cas voilà cette émission sur les 40
au saint quentin en yvelines consacré à
la santé est terminée a très vite pour
une nouvelle émission consacrée
justement à cet anniversaire